well thank you Louise and thanks to the
Library Foundation and thanks to you for
all coming out on a rainy night to see
an extraordinary man I know that you
will not be disappointed by this this
performance this evening I have since I
started doing radio broadcasts in 1992
I've probably conducted about 10 or 12
thousand interviews something along
those lines because every program has a
lot of interviews on it and we do
everything by phone those who are
repeaters I get to know in a sort of
telephone basis Chalmers Johnson is one
of those and so it's a real privilege
and pleasure for me to have met him
tonight for the first time and and to be
here even though we have talked together
many times on the radio and then off the
radio as well but again only by phone
one of the problems we have with
Chalmers is that on our program we try
to balance each each broadcast with the
people who have different points of view
about whatever the topic of the day may
be and we try to balance them in in
every way and it's very difficult to
find somebody to balance with Chalmers
by that I mean that a person who is so
relentlessly logical so wonderfully
persuasive in the way he argues so
articulate and so well informed so
fortunately we didn't have to balance
him today I don't have to argue with him
I'm just gonna ask him questions but I'm
delighted to be able to do it the latest
book of course is the sorrows of empire
and the Empire involved needless to say
is the Empire of the United States which
he argues has been brought into
existence and operated without the real
awareness or understanding of the
American people who nonetheless
are the ones who are supporting it as
you can imagine it's not a book that's
full of a lot of laughs and in fact in
the prologue he says this is not an
optimistic report and I think that may
be the only understatement in 400 pages
of material in the sorrows of empire he
says later that I fear that we will lose
our country and then apologizes lest
that be an overstatement but says he
thinks he will be forgiven by future
generations if it is an overstatement
because they'll be so glad that he was
wrong so I must say that I hope you're
wrong
but nonetheless the arguments are
persuasive and are interesting and let
us get to them but let me begin this way
I don't know if people know your
background well and it's important I
think to what you have written
particularly given the fact that the
military and the CIA are both
instruments of the Empire the verse
describes and he has been in both the
military and the CIA at the CIA at least
as an adviser and I think it's his
experience is there that have had a lot
to do with the ideas that have now
evolved into the book The Sorrows of
Empire so let's begin there tell us a
bit about your experience in the
military about your experience with the
CIA and how they were formative to what
we see in the book warning it's a great
pleasure to put name and face together
it really is to have a chance to appear
here in the Los Angeles Public Library
at this forum yes I was in the Navy
in the Korean War of the operations
officer on a rust bucket the LST 883
hauling Marines around Korea and places
like that
this was important to me because it was
my first introduction to he stage in
civilization I began studying Japanese
at the naval base in Yokosuka I returned
to Berkeley and studied Chinese and
spent my life working on the politics of
China and Japan I was a cold warrior I
did believe that the Soviet Union was a
genuine menace and in 1967 I was then
the chairman of the senator for Chinese
Studies at the University California
Berkeley I was recruited by Richard
Helms than the director of CIA soon to
be indicted for lying to Congress over
the overthrow of salvador ND in in chile
he claimed that we had nothing to do
with it of course we had everything to
do with it the I was I was in the office
of national estimates which are now in
the news again
they're extremely highly classified
papers that go to the president they're
classified primarily because they are so
unbelievably by now it would be an
embarrassment to the to the American
public to realize the quality of this is
this is what passes for a strategic
thought in the Oval Office but
nonetheless it was a certainly it was a
formative experience I won just one
anecdote from those days I do remember
that as the as Daniel Delbert Ellsberg's
Pentagon Papers began to be published in
the New York Times there was literally
cheering in the halls of Langley as the
people who had worked on Vietnam said
finally we no longer look like such a
group of fools we've been saying for a
long time that the war was unwinnable
and we had enormous respect for Ellsberg
he was as we used to say one of us he
was a Marine officer he had served in
Vietnam he had a PhD in economics from
Harvard he was a rand corporation
character my god it was easy to give him
a security clearance the and I just had
a pleasant conversation with him not too
long ago and he was saying that he
wished he'd acted earlier but what
you're wondering is well what many
people say to me things like when did
you stop being a blood lusting fascist
hyena I know but I just to put it very
briefly there were two certainly
formative influences one analytical and
the other quite concrete with the
collapse of the Soviet Union in 1991 I
believe that we should have seen a much
greater peace dividend withdrawal from
our huge deployments around the world
the Menace of the Soviet Union was gone
the Cold War was clearly over Russia is
a much smaller country
then the former Soviet Union used to be
instead our government moved at once
even before Saddam Hussein's invasion of
Kuwait moved at once to try and find
replacement enemies and to shore up the
Cold War structures in in Latin America
in East Asia
I believe this posed a major analytic
question was the Cold War a cover for
something more fundamental for an
American imperial project that probably
went back to World War two in which we
used anti-communism as a cover for
essentially imperialist activities
it was extremely convenient to us in
Latin America we've used Fidel Castro
for years to cover what were in fact
activities undertaken for the sake of
the United Fruit Company or of anaconda
copper company or something of that sort
so that I set out to investigate that
the concrete experience was a visit to
Okinawa in 1996 this is the southernmost
Japanese province prefecture it's the
poorest Prefecture in Japan it has 38
American military bases located on an
island smaller than Kauai in the
Hawaiian Islands it is the Japanese
equivalent of Puerto Rico it has been
seized by the Japanese Empire into the
19th century discriminated against ever
since and essentially used today as a
dumping ground for American troops
they'd like to maintain the Japanese
American security treaty but they don't
want the 3rd Marine Division located
anywhere close to them on September 4th
1995 an extremely serious incident
courage two Marines and a sailor from
Camp Hansen a big ugly base in the
middle of Okinawa had abducted beaten
and raped a twelve-year-old girl it
produced the largest demonstrations
against the United States since the the
security treaty was signed I was invited
by the governor of Okinawa had come to
Okinawa in February 1996 to talk to his
staff about this incident and I did so
and I was truly shocked by what I saw by
the as well as the fact that the then
the Commandant of American forces in
East Asia it was General Richard Myers
he is today of course chair
the Joint Chiefs of Staff he took the
standard routine way of dealing with
these issues to say well this is an
exceptional tragic incident three bad
apples but in no way typical of our
troops my research including research
published just quite recently has
demonstrated that the rate of sexually
violent crimes leading to court-martial
in Okinawa has for 50 years
averaged at 2 a month there was nothing
the only thing exceptional about the
rape of 1995 was that they raped a child
instead of a mature woman who very often
they depend upon the fact that she would
be so humiliated she wouldn't come
forward anyway my first reaction was
that Okinawa must be exceptional that
this place is just not nobody's paid
attention to it the military is
extremely skilled in public relations
the press never goes down there the
Japanese don't encourage you to go down
there after I began to investigate our
big American military enclaves
in the Persian Gulf in Diego Garcia in
South Korea in Japan in Germany England
Italy I discovered that Okinawa was not
exceptional it was typical that is
around what Americans don't appreciate
is that foreigners commonly the
Americans they see are not
representatives of our popular culture
or of our movies or whatever else that
we're sometimes proud of what they see
are 18 to 24 year old young men usually
in the Special Forces in well over a
hundred and thirty countries around the
world and these people live with
continuous sexual violence noise
pollution environmental pollution bar
brawls drunk driving one thing after
another
I would simply conclude by saying there
are no foreign troops based in the
United States so unless you have lived
next door to one of these bases abroad
you don't know anything about what goes
on with it next is I'm not at a position
to argue with you of course and/or
dispute your research but what reason
does the military give
for having these bases in so many
countries around the world they don't
actually give a reason the base
structure report published each year by
the Department of Defense lists at the
time of this book of 2002 725 military
bases located in other people's
countries
that's believe me considerably more than
we need for any conceivable strategic
purpose 725 is also just the official
number they leave out all the secret
bases the Espionage bases the bases in
England that are disguised as Royal Air
Force bases the three bases in Israel
that are highly secret they never
mentioned the bases in Alice Becca Stan
Kyrgyzstan Camp Bondsteel and Kosovo
they don't mention the four bases being
built as we talked in Iraq or places
like that
the this these bases came into being in
the course of fighting one or another of
our various wars we almost never give
one up when the war is over we start
dead finding new uses for it new the
only time we give them up is after we
lost a war after Vietnam we did lose our
bases in in Spain in Greece and in the
Philippines simply because they decided
it their governments that it wasn't so
useful to be allied or to be tolerant of
of the American bases but the
justification is essentially strategic
needs in without ever saying so in so
many words to maintain American hegemony
over the globe American hegemony or
stability in various parts of the world
what's the difference
stability is an odd term I know they
love it that's the kind of word they
they started to use when they were
looking for a replacement for the Soviet
Union as teachers of international
relations say by the very nature of the
international system it is unstable the
issue is never stability the issue is
whether the stability is of any
importance to our country the
instability where it may or may not
occur so they claim that they're also
maintaining stability but at the same
time I mean for example secretary
Rumsfeld was just recently in Okinawa
and said to the governor that the bases
there were justified by the stability
that we had brought to the area without
for 50 years without ever mentioning
either the Korean or Vietnamese Wars
that had occurred throughout this period
in which Okinawa was a major launching
area for these things or all the other
numerous smaller incidents like East
Timor or or whatever else it's not clear
in that in any sense
our extremely high-tech military brings
stability to anything it may very well
produce the opposite and it certainly
produces anti-americanism are we not to
protecting regimes that are allied with
us for various purposes the military
actually prefers regimes that are not
democratic that is they're in fact one
of the specific justifications today for
the removal of the basis of Germany into
places poor former communist countries
like Romania and Bulgaria is that the
Germans demand much higher standards of
environmental protection than they do
and the military has said in so many
words we can be dirty in these countries
the Status of Forces agreements that we
impose on all countries exempt us from
ever cleaning up the messes that we that
we make in some cases we are dealing
with allies but let's take Kyrgyzstan
and Uzbekistan part of the military
petroleum complex and our attempts to
bring the oil of the Caspian Basin under
our control
we've built military bases there one of
them is called the the Captain Peter J
gun C jr. Air Force Base Peter J gun she
is the highest ranking fireman in the
New York Fire Department who lost his
life on 9/11
the Russians have now just built a new
base 40 miles away it's the first
military base Russia has built since the
collapse the Soviet Union they're
clearly trying to to balance us the
governments of Kyrgyzstan and Uzbekistan
are probably as right-wing authoritarian
old apparatchiks left over from the
Soviet Union as you could find I mean
that is our president loves to go out of
his he's been quoted by Bob Woodward of
the Washington Post how helos Kim
jong-il of North Korea
these two guys make Kim jong-il look
like a fairly decent neighbor
the and they've both been welcomed to
the to the Oval Office it always reminds
me that when he said he loathed Kim
jong-il of North Korea I always crossed
my mind George Bush and Kim jong-il do
have one thing in common
neither of them would be where they are
without their daddies neither of them
could conceivably have risen above gas
station attendant with you know without
without that but no it's it's not at all
clear that the United that is the United
States has an almost impeccable record
in East Asia of sponsoring
anti-democratic regimes of bringing
military officers to power that one of
our greatest allies on earth today is
general pervez musharraf of Pakistan who
after all came to power in the Clinton
administration through a military
overthrow of a democratically elected
government we have we have laws that
there is us to keep us from
participating with with such people so
that yes you may say that we are in a
certain sense protecting our allies and
it did make sense at one time during the
Cold War when we were a status quo power
attempting to build an edifice of
legality of international law of the
United Nations the use of foreign aid in
as a as a tool of diplomacy something we
pioneered but and then we were doing
this against the revisionist powers the
powers that were trying to change the
world like Nazi Germany or Imperial
Japan or Mao's China or the Soviet Union
today I think you would have to say that
we are without question the most
revisionist of revisionist powers we we
openly proclaim we are the new Rome we
are beyond good and evil we are beyond
the need for friends we are beyond the
need for the United Nations Paul
Wolfowitz first that is the assistant
secretary defense virtually uses the old
Roman phrase we do do not care whether
they love us so long as they fear us
this is so that's in in that sense I
find it stretching a point to say that
we are doing this for the benefit of
anyone
you've experienced the current president
but obviously you think this goes back
to a previous administration's as well
when did it go wrong when or when did
things go wrong according to your
request yet I mean precisely I'm this
book is not particularly an anti Bush
book I mean I wouldn't want to kid you
if this is in the Chinese calendar the
year of the monkey and I'd vote for a
monkey to do it to replace the current
government but the senator Johnson's
views are his and not those of the
management quit absolutely if we have a
free exchange of ideas in the Los
Angeles Public Library but that I think
the critical mistake
I believe mistake in the in the
Talleyrand sense of fundamental
irreparable strategic error was in 1991
with the collapse of the Soviet Union
and bear in mind
it happened rapidly we didn't anticipate
it the CIA
radically overestimated the size of the
Soviet economy in the 1980s I mean if if
we were having this conversation in 1985
and I had said to you five years from
now the Soviet Union will disappear you
would have thought this guy's inhaling
too deeply on something growing around
the Berkeley campus I mean this is not a
this is this is not a reliable
commentator well it's gone it it came
apart for forces that are also
influencing us in this country today too
that is in 1991 we concluded wrongly
that we had won the Cold War we simply
didn't lose it as badly as they did
because we were richer than they were
and it took us longer to do so we had
absolutely nothing we did had anything
to do with the collapse of the Soviet
Union least of all Reagan's Star Wars we
know that in detail
Gorbachev brought sucker off into the
pull it and I ballistic missile defense
and he gave a brilliant exposition and
they spent not a ruble on it the this
was an error we concluded now in
virtually the words of Paul Wolfowitz in
the orig
draft of what is now today the national
security document vote of September 2002
but that was first written in the last
years of the first Bush administration
that our policy now is to maintain
absolute dominance over the world
militarily ultimately from bases in
outer space that and this is to keep
under control everyone that is not
enemies every source of power including
allies that might ultimately compete
with this this I think is a kind of
hubris a kind of arrogance a kind of
unreality that begins to well it
separates us away from the rest of the
world we do we like many people in
Washington or at least in the Pentagon
do like this phrase the new Rome we're
beginning to behave like the Roman
Empire and with the I mentioned this
simply of course the Roman Empire it
took 300 years to fall the collapse of
empires is now starting to come sort of
with the speed of FedEx the the the
thousand-year Reich lasted twelve years
from 1933 to the sack of Berlin in 1945
by the Red Army the Soviet Union's
empire fell apart between 1989 and 1991
ours is may well be beyond the Rubicon
already as it is in terms of Imperial
overstretch but I think this is when we
started to go wrong was when we
concluded that wrongly that we had won
the Cold War and were therefore no
longer there were no longer challenges
or threats to us from the rest of the
world in any military sense you just use
the term overstretch what about the fact
that many in the military apparently now
are very concerned that we are
overstretched in terms of our military
capability and not likely to be able to
do much about it with a volunteer army
and reserves now being used up it's my
understanding there are a lot of people
in the Pentagon very very conservative
but I do feel that the war in Iraq was a
poorly it was was misjudged
no question about that I mean it is one
of the great restraints on our Empire
that now is starting to show up where do
we get the cannon fodder the it's not
been an obligation of citizenship just
defend the country since 1973 it is a
career choice it is not those of you who
are veterans of World War two or Korea
or Vietnam simply wouldn't recognize
life in the Armed Forces today it's a
you don't do KP anymore you don't clean
latrines
that's all farmed out to companies like
Kellogg Brown and Root subsidiary of
Cheney's Halliburton very lucrative Lee
because you've got to make life in the
Armed Forces attractive it starts to
develop a that moreover people join the
military to date largely because or in
many cases they do so to escape one or
another dead end of our society
that's why african-americans are twice
as well represented in the army as they
are in the society as a whole
50% of the women in the Armed Forces our
national minorities I thought it was
telling when PFC Jessica Lynch was
wounded at NASA Rhea and the press asked
her why'd she joined the Army just I
couldn't get a job a Walmart in
Palestine West Virginia I it was a it
was my way out I joined the army to get
out of Palestine West Virginia the
important point she didn't expect to be
shot and most of the people being
joining the army
do not expect to be shot at and that is
one of the great restraints we have on
the Armed Forces right now is we will
see at a very short period of time
whether you can continue to attract
sufficient numbers of people into the
Armed Forces to fulfill our Imperial
plans or whether we have to go to
something very politically loaded like a
draft or probably in the back of most of
the planners Minds is a traditional
imperialist strategy start looking for
foreign cannon fodder see boys we did
that in Vietnam with muntin yards and
and among people and things like that
we're certainly trying it today a track
trying to attract alleged coalition
partners like the Japanese or the or the
Dutch or the pole
or whatever to send troops to to Iraq it
is of course the danger in that strategy
is are they loyal I mean when we use the
word see poised or that was the Sepoy
Rebellion of 1857 in India most of the
British Army in India was made up of
Indian troops and when they revolted it
became well known in Indian history the
first movement of mass of liberation of
India from British imperialism but it's
a major constraint of whether we will
run out of the manpower and woman power
today to to staff the Empire and it as
well as the fact that it's unimaginably
expensive when other countries are
willing to send troops to whatever for
whatever purpose to Iraq or any place
else where we have where we are engaged
isn't that an indication of
international support for whatever it is
that is being done doesn't it validate
the policy as it so often target if we
could only get the UN to would be more
involved with Iraq have troops from
other countries as the Democratic
candidates have been advocating then
we'll have a kind of validity and an
acceptance in that part of the world
that we simply don't know well that's
what the the White House would like you
to believe and says it on the on the
evening news owned by the entertainment
conglomerates the but the truth the
matter is people cooperate with us
because of the threat of retaliation
because of the fear that a country as
powerful as ours is with vast I mean the
major international economic
institutions the World Bank the World
Trade Organization and the International
Monetary Fund as the demonstrators in
Seattle in November 1999 demonstrate
showed to the rest of the world these
are among the most anti-democratic not
undemocratic anti-democratic
institutions that exist on earth and
they're completely under the thumb of of
the US Treasury they can be used if need
be to even just the threat of they're
being used isn't enough to cause most
countries to do come along with us
the thing that is Astana
to me today is that to such powerful
countries as France and Germany should
have decided to stand aloof that
countries that could have avoided our
might make might makes right adventure
in in Iraq Japan Britain Australia
they've actually are isolating
themselves badly I mean one of the
results of what's happened in Iraq is it
Britain simply will never for decades
have influence on the continent again
there's not trusted any longer you could
get rid of Tony Blair but indeed it's
stuck around the world that Blair is
Bush's poodle and Koizumi is his cocker
spaniel that they these people
understand the the the nature of power
in the world at the same time there is
growing inevitably because of the
openness of the administration in its
dropping of its mask and what it wants
to do compared to the world of Bill
Clinton where he protected himself by by
putting it under globalization or
humanitarian intervention or some other
rubric that suggested it wasn't simply
American policy to maintain hegemony
over the world but that now we have this
this situation of openness that has
started to lead to I mean a year ago in
February of 2003 10 million people in
every democracy on earth demonstrated
against the Bush administration the war
in Iraq and for democracy 400,000 in New
York two million in London the largest
demonstration in British history a
million each in Berlin Madrid Rome those
people haven't gone away they're there
their organization today is virtually a
guarantee of it's as if a new superpower
were rising to thwart the ambitions of
the United States I recommend to all of
you that you read Arundhati Roy
brilliant speech to the the world Social
Forum that just closed in Bombay she
calls her speech do the turkeys enjoy
Thanksgiving
but she's basically talking about is
that peculiar American custom now of the
president's sparing a single turkey for
a happy life in a Virginia farm is while
we eat the rest of them regardless as a
metaphor for America's attitudes toward
the third world but she ends her speech
I mean it is the winner of the Booker
Prize and she she fascinates me because
she says things nobody else ever says
and the moment she says it did they
become common knowledge but she ends by
saying I'm tired of demonstrating I want
a boycott of cutsies people on
everywhere they are everything they
produce everything that happens a
boycott starting that just starts off
with ten million people is is a
restraint on on a country like ours so
that it's not as though well I mean
maybe we are the new Rome but our
decline has started freddie rapidly you
talked about the clinton administration
and said that it had been shielded and
in certain ways sure that President
Clinton shielded himself from was
essentially the same kind of thing that
the Bush administration is doing what
about the Balkans in Kosovo why on earth
would we want to be concerned about that
- part of the world what interest do we
have there it's a wonderful question
delighted to answer it I mean it is to
say Bill Clinton said we'd only be there
for six months the current president
campaigned on the idea that we shouldn't
be there at all that what is this
peacekeeping operation to protect the
Kosovar Albanians from Serbs
well there's a base there called Camp
Bondsteel it's not listed in the base
structure report the army proudly says
there are only two things - man-made
objects you can see from outer space the
Great Wall of China and Camp Bondsteel
it is it was built in 1999 the richest
base we've built since the Vietnam War
was built by Kellogg Brown and Root of
of Halliburton it lies directly athwart
the proposed a pipeline across the
Balkans that Kellogg Brown and Root have
already also surveyed that is the plan
we had a coup d'etat just a few weeks
ago in in in Georgia to make sure that
we have a friendly government there as
begin to extract oil from the Caspian
Sea move it through Georgia to the Black
Sea across the Black Sea to Bulgaria and
then across the Balkans to the Adriatic
coast in Albania avoiding the Bosporus
and Dardanelles that are too narrow they
limit ships 250,000 tonnes going through
there
the Camp Bondsteel lies directly a fort
this this pipeline and is part of what
we call the military petroleum complex
much of our I mean today we are
motivated to maintain our profligate use
of fossil fuels and have refused to to
conserve in any way even though we've
had the technology for some time to
eliminate entirely our dependence on on
Persian Gulf oil the symbol of the
United States after 9/11 in Europe
became some sort of love
youthful lout driving a Chevrolet
Suburban down the down the freeways with
a American flag attached with antenna
the I think the suburban gets about 11
miles the gallon its sales doubled in
the years after 9/11 extremely
profitable product for General Motors
it's a choice we use more petroleum than
anybody else does we also think that we
can exercise control over potential
sources of power in the future such as
China grew at nine point one percent
last year
it is easily the fastest growing large
economy on earth today that we could use
oil to to control them in the future so
that that is we're looking at the whole
Southern Eurasian world opened up by the
collapse of the Soviet Union from the
Balkans to China as it stands right now
with our positions in Iraq and
Afghanistan as well as in Central Asia
we have only Iran stands in the way
that's therefore it's not accidental
that it appears on the the axis of evil
he traveled in this part of the world as
swum in the Caspian Sea it has a
distinctly oily smell to it the when I
did it it was was back in Brezhnev days
it was better known for sturgeon and
caviar but baker-bots the firm of the
great Republican Secretary of State Jim
Baker has a a law office in Baku
Azerbaijan there's not too much legal
business to do in Baku not too many I
mean that is that the American
ambassador to Kazakhstan very pleasant
extremely well-educated woman drove her
car around the capital of Kazakhstan
with a buffer strip on it that said
happy is happiness is twin pipelines she
was thinking thinking of the pipeline's
across Afghanistan from Tajikistan to
for the Union Oil Company to the Arabian
Sea in in Pakistan its we're in the
Balkans for oil politics not to save
Kosovars what would you say to an
American who said ok if in fact we have
this kind of hegemony over the rest of
the world if we can exert this kind of
power if we can engineer Cousteau in
Georgia or anyplace else and feed
ourselves and and our way of living at
the same time and and I do so without
the fear of attack by anybody why
shouldn't we sit back and enjoy it yes
well this is the reason I've tried did
I've written this book it's a sequel to
a book that I published in the year 2000
called blowback the costs and
consequences of American Empire blowback
as a CIA term it
it means retaliation obviously it first
was used in the after-action report on
the overthrow of Mossadegh in Iran in
1953 for the sake of the British
Petroleum Company we accused him of
being a communist the Pope would
probably fit that category more
accurately than Mohammad Mossadegh did
we brought the Shah to power
notoriously but that the I conclude by
what I'm trying to do in this book is to
lay out a vast amount of information and
what I hope is a readable manner that
I'm reasonably certain Americans don't
have and they desperately need to have
it they need to know about the base
world they need to know about the
interests there they need to understand
what George Washington was talking about
in his farewell address when he warned
against the influence of standing armies
what Dwight Eisenhower was was talking
about in his farewell address in 1961
when he invented the phrase
military-industrial complex he meant to
say military industrial congressional
complex we know from his papers but was
warned off from from doing that the we
may have already passed across the
Rubicon it may be irreversible a genuine
American Hero like Senator Robert Byrd
from West Virginia continues to give
these impassioned and intelligent and
informed speeches knowledgeable of
American history in empty in empty
Senate chambers he's our Cicero the he
he I think well by our society just be
ignored as an old man from a fourth
state Cicero ended up with his head in
both hands nailed to the Forum wall by
the on the then boy Emperor Octavian
soon to become the god Augustus Caesar
the end to institute of military
dictatorship my four sorrows that I end
with and why I I stress this were our
perpetual war the President and Vice
President have identified between fifty
and sixty countries they would like to
do regime change in using our military
secondly the losses that they've done
that publicly they've done that publicly
yes it was that Cheney first said fifty
and then in the West Point speech Bush
raised him to sixty the the second is
the loss of the Republic
it is the irreversible damage of the
Constitution I mean the most important
author of the Constitution James Madison
wrote under the name Publius used
referring to our Roman antecedents in
the Federalist Papers that the single
most important article in the
Constitution was the one that gave the
power to declare war exclusively to the
electorate representatives of the people
never under any circumstances should it
be entrusted to a single man the
responsibility was too great in October
of 2002 our Congress gave that power to
a single man on his say-so when he felt
like it including the use of nuclear
weapons if he cares to do so and it
helps sell the Congress by doing by
creating a false a National Intelligence
Estimate on Iraq in the same month that
was passed to Congress essentially a
National Intelligence Estimate in which
the CIA was ordered to find the evidence
to back up the speeches that Vice
President Cheney is already given now
the as we talked articles four and six
of the Bill of Rights are dead letters
you do not have to say the Presidents
invented a new category known as and I'm
not kidding you and I'm not being
sarcastic it is known as bad guy and if
if the president declares you a bad guy
he even though you're a native-born
citizen he can throw you in a naval brig
in Charleston South Carolina and keep
you there we're about soon to find in
the next few months whether or not the
Supreme Court that appointed this
president would care to address these
issues but the these are the I mean
we're talking about very serious
incident here the third of my sorrows of
empire is disinformation it is lying to
the public by the government probably
the most serious example we've had it
goes on every day with weapons of mass
destruction so-called what was February
5th last year the Secretary of State
Colin Powell in the UN Security Council
with the director of Central
Intelligence sitting like a potted plant
behind him so that he's his face
appeared in any television picture
allegedly providing verisimilitude
trying to recreate the scene in the
Security Council when Adlai Stevenson
came in with
YouTube pictures of the Russian missiles
in in Cuba precipitating the Cuban
Missile Crisis what we offered our
evidence the world we now know that
everything Colin Powell said that day
was alive and he had ample reason to
know it was that it was manufactured and
wrong there is not a serious informed
statesman on earth today that would
believe a word said by the secretary of
state of the United States he's lost all
credibility but this is the cost of of
this kind of thing but fourth and
perhaps most obvious that we face is
bankruptcy you
we simply when you have spending a half
trillion dollars a year on the military
four hundred thousand four hundred
billion dollar defense budget leaving
aside Iraq and Afghanistan plus at least
another twenty billion in the Department
of Energy for atomic energy it comes out
about a half trillion dollars a year we
can't afford that we're not funding it
it is we're going deeply into debt as
Herbert Stein when he was a Republican
chairman of the Council of Economic
Advisers once put it things that can't
go on forever don't that's that's what's
happening you simply mean even if the
American public is willing to kiss off
their constitution the the economic
crisis is likely to catch up with this
anyway I've seen it reported that
despite the vast sums that you mention
it the defense spending at the moment is
only about five percent of GNP which is
roughly what it was during the Reagan
years hasn't gone up that much it's
actually it sucks you eighths in I tried
to discuss it in some ways it that is it
there's been four great peaks of defense
spending one is right now but generally
it never goes below a Cold War norm of
approximately it's three hundred fifty
billion dollars a year and it is argue
question can we afford this level of
expenditure we don't manufacture much in
America anymore we are in our 25th month
of recovery that has produced almost no
jobs it's unprecedented in American
economic history we have that is the new
a group of 20 that emerged at the World
Trade Organization meeting in in Cancun
in the Mexican resort town last autumn
which is opposing us directly opposing
our economic policies for the rest of
the world the my argument is that I
don't think we can just afford anything
that the one of the reasons I say this
is because precisely the precedent of
what happened to the Soviet Union the
Soviet Union collapsed for three basic
reasons because of extreme ideological
rigidity in their domestic economic
institutions making it very hard to
reform them this the influence the power
of Stalinism even though they many
people in the leadership were aware that
it no longer made any sense do we have
that in America well that's what Enron
what the looting of pension funds what
the what Martha Stewart what corruption
in the mutual fund industry the distrust
of the New York Stock Exchange that's
what's all that's what that's all about
that we shows the same thing the second
thing that brought down the Soviet Union
was Imperial overstretch that is the
they simply couldn't continue to afford
to meet us everywhere on earth well what
is Imperial overstretch I'd say 725
military bases in other people's
countries is about as good a definition
of of Imperial overstretch as I could
think of and finally inability to reform
is he as a professor of international
relations we usually argue that no
Empire ever gives up voluntarily I can
think of one exception to it one case
that came pretty close to being an
empire that gave up voluntarily and that
was the Soviet Union under Mikhail
Gorbachev he made the decision that
Russia would be better off with friendly
relations with France and Germany than
with these crummy East European
satellites that they'd kept since us as
1945 and therefore he did not use the
Red Army against the protestors who in
November 1989 breached the Berlin Wall
but my point is Gorbachev was then
stopped cold by vested interests
in the Soviet system he couldn't get
around it now do I think those vested
interests exist in the United States
well to ask the question is to answer it
that is the military-industrial complex
that that Eisenhower warned us against
the huge myth it is among the best ways
to get rich in America if you're a
politically with well-connected
capitalist is in the arms industry is in
the service of the Armed Forces the of
the fifty seven billion dollars just
appropriated for Iraq a good third of it
is going into private hands to maintain
the the Armed Forces in in the field the
private military companies today do
everything but pull the trigger and so
that my argument is that it's it's that
is we have to be careful about whether
we can afford these things just
endlessly indefinitely I think history
suggests to us that we can't it reminds
me once that Paul Kennedy who wrote the
important book called the rise and
decline of great powers he he once said
as he was traveling he's a professor at
Yale but an Englishman that and
traveling in America people used to
stand up and say to a professor Kennedy
are you are you really saying that the
decline of the United States is
inevitable and he said no I'm not saying
that is just simply I can't think of the
evidence for the opposite point of view
I mean of what body of evidence you care
to offer a halfway intelligent person
that the United States
goes on forever like it was Apollo or
something as you said in the prologue
this is not an optimistic report there
are a lot of questions that I would like
to ask but I'm sure there are questions
that you would like to ask and let me
give you an opportunity to do that yes
the lady with the white black and white
sweater is it just we the united states
ends up not having it's 736 bases around
the world or the secret ones and comes
back to the United States and
starts acting like a democratic country
or what can everybody hear that question
the what happens how does it end will it
be a happy end I guess it is really the
question it's being asked soft landing I
think they often say it and things like
ah history would suggest to us that they
are not soft landings that they come out
rather badly the that is what one would
advocate this is what being senator byrd
in his heart obviously believes and says
so that the American public when finally
fully informed will reassert their
democratic control and reestablish their
republic revolt against the people who
have been cheating them I'm not at all
certain that that's true or they could
even possibly get the information to do
so given the control of the media and
and things like that that those of us
who are opposed to the war party well we
have on our side the internet the the
Nation magazine
Paul Krugman a few others but and that's
one of the things that makes the
difference is that we're reading things
like anti-war calm every morning it's a
Gazette of information around the world
on on where these things sit but how
would it that is to say what we're
advocating is a return to constitutional
foreign policy a return to a
reinvigoration of the Congress as
genuine representatives of the people
this might require an almost total
recasting of the states in this country
because of our electoral districts
simply are incoherent today the in terms
of of the population and the needs of
the of the country the it would mean a
reliance on the demonstration effects of
the United States we used to hold
ourselves up as a model for the rest of
the world it would certainly mean a
return to that line in the Declaration
of Independence that says we have we
seek the good respect of the rest of
mankind we don't seem to do that any
longer and things like that there are
common knowledge and fairly sensible in
that certainly a reliance on trade as a
form
of mutually beneficial activity not a
way to screw Mexican farmers which is
what it is pretty much today the but how
it actually will end I think is that
history would tell us it's much more
likely to end in a severe crack-up as
the justice did is for example in the
case of the Soviet Union as we waste our
resources in in the military certainly
one of the things that would require is
one of my criticisms of of the
Democratic Party at the present time
I appreciate Howard Dean's raising of
these issues because I do believe that
the Constitution was the issue but no
Democrat has yet even begun to set out
for us what we need in the way of a
military to protect the country - that
is militarism is not the same thing as
national defense no one opposes national
defense militarism is is the
glorification of profiting from the
military as a way of life and it is I
mean right now the amount of money spent
by the United States on foreign affairs
ninety three percent of it is spent by
the Pentagon seven percent by the State
Department that's where our priorities
are at the present time
it would mean an altering of those
priorities it would mean the kind of
demobilization that the United States
experienced very rapidly after World War
two a reorientation of the society to
civilian pursuits do I think that's
possible I I doubt it I mean so often
when questions like yours get asked to
me by somebody who says well what do you
think you should we should do my wife
says you must say something other than
this but I have on one or two occasions
said if you've got a little money ahead
think about a condo in Vancouver I mean
think about your escape route is is what
is what is is fine my most serious
advice the end and look around and see
if you have the ability of acquiring any
other kind of passport a second passport
is occasionally quite useful thing in
this world
of inter-community Greece is one of the
most anti-american countries on earth
they remember the Greek Colonels we put
him in power between 1967 and 1973
probably the most odious regime created
by either side in the Cold War if you're
thinking of going to the Olympic Games
in Greece brought back to Greece this
coming summer and you've got a French
passport or a Brazilian passport
it would be just elementary prudence to
use it they may not have the the
stadium's ready by the time the Olympics
are held yes up in the back go ahead
what are they for did the Americans wear
uniforms what are we use before the
questions about the secret bases
allegedly in Israel what are they for
and are the American soldiers their best
in in uniforms we're not sure
these have been reported but mutlar
they've been reported they've been
things like the letter Review of Books
details I mean we get we get information
on the secret bases in England from a
very interest interesting woman I'd like
to offer her some credit here
Linda's Percy of the Committee for
nuclear disarmament she spends her time
breaking into American military bases
she is charged to demonstrate what goes
on there she is then invariably charged
with criminal trespass and as she goes
to court the u.s. embassy drops all
charges because to pursue the case gives
her a chance to say what she found she
was last seen brilliantly nailing or
attaching of an American flag upside
down to the gates of Buckingham Palace
during the visit of the boy Emperor this
this this past autumn what's your
evidence though for the bases in Israel
journalists who know a good deal about
what these bases look like they're
undercover if for maintaining peace on
the Egyptian border in the Negev but the
entire flight the aircraft off the USS
Eisenhower were flown off into a base in
in Israel they're widely discussed in
Haaretz in in Jerusalem the were
actually sent the papers in Tel Aviv
the but that I don't know much more than
that except that they're there that they
are included in our plans the global
security organization tries to track
them but every bit of information you
get is from other than official sources
yes sir and you know dynamic with the
military
you've got me thinking when you talk
about how we are people refused to
implement any form of conservation and I
guess this is really a chicken and egg
kind of question which is justifying
which is the military present their
presents to to support our oil
consumption or is it really vice versa
well I don't think we heard that one
yeah so you make a point is the military
which military occupation you're talking
about in part that's the case or whether
or not we're using a massive consumption
to justify the extension of Empire okay
everybody go ahead I think it's a
perfectly good question and it's a it's
a thing you'd have to argue I mean it
would run one way or I mean it can run
both ways that indeed our consumption of
of fossil fuels turns into something
called our way of life and and if that's
what we that is our way of life then
that's what our army is supposed to
defend at the same time the military
often finds that it wishes to control of
a resource diplomacy as as old an issue
in international relations as one could
find and they're controlling a valuable
resource my reason for raising the issue
of conservation we know how to deal with
terrorist incidents the we have a great
deal of experience in this area and it's
not mysterious you do not use high-tech
military to go in and kick down doors
and and and holler peace and freedom in
English to a group of Arabic speakers
the that's what the
anticipate is a military overreaction
that will make the situation worse and
it's arguably worse that is between 1993
and 2001 including 9/11 al-qaeda carried
out five major bombings worldwide since
that time in two years down to and
including the suicide attacks in eastern
ball against the HSBC bank and against
the British Consulate they successfully
carried out 17 in the the the cold hard
slog long hard slog memo of secretary
Rumsfeld last October he said we don't
have a metric I think he means measure
we don't have a measure for whether
we're winning or losing the war on
terrorism well you certainly do have a
measure we're losing it that we played
directly into their hands but I raised
this to say the only way to go about it
is to separate the activists from their
passive supporters so that they the
passive supporters will then supply you
with information on who the terrorists
are so they can be apprehended arrested
and brought to trial the only way you
can separate them from these active
supporters separate their passive
populations is by responding to their
legitimate grievances by alteration of
your foreign policy I believe that after
9/11 had we instantaneously done three
things withdrawn our troops from Saudi
Arabia that never should have been put
there in 1991 anyway and which we did
take them out the moment we had defeated
Baghdad it would have made a difference
that we should have also recognized that
as a matter of national policy we in the
United States stand for the ultimate
security of Israel but that the policies
of the share own government against the
Palestinians are actually made it
impossible to have us trusted in any
Islamic country on earth and in fact are
adding very greatly to the long-range
dangers to Israel I believe that we
should have stopped the three billion
dollars of Pentagon money per annum to
Israel until they withdrew from the
occupied territories in the West Bank
I mean Israel is not a small country it
has the largest fleet of s16 s on earth
in the United States it is an atomic
power it is easily the most powerful
country in in the Middle East I believe
this would have made a difference and
then third had we then begun to
eliminate the leverage of the oil
countries like Saudi Arabia and Iraq and
Iran on us by freeing ourselves from the
dependence on on petroleum for our
automotive industry this would have had
added an element of credibility to what
we were doing I believe had we done
these three things al Qaeda would be of
interest primarily to Chiefs of Police
today the we and we would be well on our
way toward rounding him up the French
and the Germans have already in the
attend the Spaniards have done a
wonderful job of rounding up these
activists in Western Europe already yes
sir and the price will become
uncontrollable with the devastating
effects on food production and many
other things
do you have any comments on that
gentleman's asking what happens when we
run out of oil basically when we run out
of cheap oil
yeah you're absolutely right it's not
rocket science to say that that's what's
happening it's why
Toyota is is working day and night on a
post petroleum automobile whereas we are
not the it is why we have to face the
fact that though Iraq was attractive to
us because it has the second largest oil
reserves on earth still the largest on
earth are those in Saudi Arabia and our
policies there are virtually asking for
an anti-american revolution against the
House of Saud and I mean that is to say
the thing that has ruined our
middle-eastern policy it was built on
two pillars our relations with Saudi
Arabia our relations with Iran the
Iranian pillar fell in 1979 when the
Shah was overthrown because of our
history of interfering in in politics
the we are now were
that this could happen in Saudi Arabia
but as you just made the case Saudi
Arabia has its reserves are so large
that use a country that uses as much oil
as we do can't do without it and they're
the only country on earth that can
produce petroleum at a relatively cheap
price and still make it economical as
distinct from exporting oil from say the
Caspian Basin where the Caspian Sea is
totally landlocked it's so if you've got
really difficult chores of getting it
out and taking it through places like
Chechnya Dagestan or or uh Kurdistan
Turkey are our faces were just widely
open to sabotage so that yes of course
I regard it as a short term and not very
well thought through to think that you
can perpetuate our our extra elaborate
use of fossil fuels indefinitely also in
order to do that we had to simply ignore
the growing evidence of global warming
withdrawn from the international efforts
to control greenhouse gases which has
again it's not just that this was a
mistake
it also conveyed to the rest of the
world that the United States had
abandoned its historic efforts which for
which I think we ought to be enormous ly
proud since world war ii to build an
edifice of international law of the
united nations of organizations like the
International Criminal Court which we
signed the original treaty and then we
have now denounced it the that the Kyoto
Protocol was not perfect without
question but we then just announced it
and walked away from it the other
industrial nations spent their time
trying to modify it in such a way that
it made it a little bit easier on the
advanced industrial countries and then
have tried to put it into effect
it's our pulling out of that conveys
that we're simply no longer a good
citizen we're not cooperative and I'm
sorry to say there will be an awful lot
of people on the world around the world
who when the American Empire goes down
they will feel as bad about it as they
did when the Soviet empire went down I
think we have time for just one more
question
yes writer and the media putting his
sins out there and having him pay it is
it possible that George Bush will come
to the same kind of situation or has the
conglomeration of the media made that
kind of situation impossible and for
example with Daniel Ellsberg be able to
get the Pentagon Papers out today
question is would given the fate of
Richard Nixon who was elected
overwhelmingly and the reelected in 1972
only to resign shortly thereafter could
the same kind of thing happened to the
current president the only prophet who
was ever any good was Cassandra she was
she has a wonderful record beware of
Greeks bearing gifts and there was
something in that horse that the in the
view that you should pay attention to I
am obviously not as as clear-sighted as
as Cassandra I don't know the answer to
that question but I am inclined to argue
that the fate of individuals is less
important here than the fate of
institutions of re-education of
Americans to their democratic heritage
to the understanding of what it means
when our original founding fathers said
that the price of Liberty is eternally
eternal vigilance this during the 1990s
when we were spending our time trying to
impeach a present resident because of an
alleged love affair that should only
event of interest probably to his wife
the that we are beginning to I mean what
does worry me is the thought the the
views of a lot of people on 9/11 around
the world the Americans had it coming
that we are asking for it that we are
and we are displaying hubris arrogance
pride nemesis is the god of vent goddess
of vengeance
of the retribution of people who behave
as we do I in my book by saying I have
the distinct feeling that nemesis is
waiting impatiently for her meeting with
us we are going to leave it at that
The Sorrows of Empire Chalmers Johnson
the he'll be signing books back to the
library foundation and all of you for
being here tonight
let me thank one only two it's a great
pleasure to meet you